what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if
you're new here my name is richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
all things data data science statistics
and programming subscribe for all kinds
of content just like this and hit the
notification Bell so YouTube notifies
you whenever I upload a video this is my
statistics tutorial series where I give
you all the statistics knowledge that
you need to conquer the data science
world in a lot of applied statistics and
data science work you have to estimate
some kind of unknown quantity but here's
the thing it's generally not enough just
to provide a point estimate you have to
provide some kind of interval estimate
and this accomplishes two things you're
communicating how far off you might be
in either direction as well as how sure
you are in your estimate now I'm also
going to come back to this point but the
assumption you're generally gonna make
is that this unknown quantity has a
fixed value that is there is one fixed
true quantity here for the entire
population again more on that point in a
little bit the most common tool for
providing interval estimates is what's
called a confidence interval which comes
with a corresponding confidence level so
we're going to talk about these today
we're gonna talk about the foundation
for them how you create them and then
some of the practical issues with them
that you're gonna come across in the
real world just as an example let's just
say hypothetically I want to know how
many hours on average people in the
United States spend on their phones in a
day the best possible way that I can
answer that question would be to take a
census of the entire population that is
I survey every single person that's
relevant inside the entire population
and I collect their data or I ask the
question the problem with that is that's
logistically a nightmare it's expensive
its time-consuming nobody really does
that so what you have to do instead is
you have to take a sample and you have
to make inferences from that sample to
the entire population this also needs to
be a random sample that we can
reasonably assume is representative of
our entire population
on that towards the end of this video
now just to lay the foundation here we
do have to go through a few definitions
so it's important to understand the
difference between a parameter and a
statistic a parameter is a fixed
generally unknown quantity of an entire
population of interest that's what we're
interested in learning about here today
specifically we're trying to estimate a
population mean which is a type of
parameter and we'll represent that
population mean with the symbol mu a
statistic is a quantity that you've
gathered from a sample and it's likely
going to be different each and every
single sample that you take now there's
tons of different examples of different
statistics the one we're going to see
the most in this example exercise is a
sample mean and you represent a sample
mean with x-bar now that we have those
definitions down it's time to finish
setting up this problem so we're going
to survey 50 different people and we're
going to ask them how many hours they
spend using their cell phone or really
what we're probably going to do is we're
just going to use the data that's
automatically generated by the phone
then we're going to use our sample size
our sample mean and our sample standard
deviation to make a 95% confidence
interval for the thing we're truly
interested in here which is the true
population mean number of hours that
Americans spend on their phones daily so
let's suppose we did our survey of 50
people we found that our sample mean
x-bar was 3.2 hours and our sample
standard deviation s is 1.2 hours now
just right off the bat that sample mean
3.2 hours is our estimate of the true
population mean now every confidence
interval is of the same general form
it's your estimate of the parameter of
interest plus or minus a margin of error
we're going to build a 95% confidence
interval here but the programmer or
study designer has completely free rein
over what confidence level they want to
select it's pretty common to see 90
percent or 95 percent or 99 percent
confidence intervals but that's mostly
just because they're nice-looking
numbers and you can pick
whatever confidence level that you want
there are trade-offs with the lower or
higher confidence levels related to
what's called statistical power as well
as type 1 and type 2 errors but that's a
subject for a different video the 95%
confidence interval is the most commonly
used interval in the statistical
community and it's a little bit
arbitrary but it's generally because
it's a good middle ground between the
various trade offs also know that the
higher your confidence level the wider
your confidence interval is going to be
now that may seem a little bit
counterintuitive at first but just think
of this extreme example if you wanted a
100% confidence interval you would
literally have to go from negative
infinity to infinity to have a hundred
percent confidence that your parameter
is within that range we're actually
building confidence by increasing the
range that is the net of possible values
that this thing could lie inside then
for our example our formula for our
confidence interval is x-bar plus or
minus T times the standard error of X
bar where the standard error of X bar is
equal to the sample standard deviation s
divided by the square root of n now that
entire piece T times the standard error
of X bar is what's called the margin of
error the statistical foundation for a
confidence interval working is the
central limit theorem if you haven't
seen my video on the central limit
theorem I'll have a card for it up above
think of the quantity T as a multiplier
which we can learn by using a T
distribution now for proportions we
actually would use a normal 0 1
distribution but for means we have to
use the T distribution and the reason
for that is a subject for a different
video one comment on the T distribution
it has only one parameter and that's
what's called the degrees of freedom now
that may seem complex and it is a little
bit weird of a concept but it's
absolutely nothing crazy degrees of
freedom in statistical terms is just the
number of pieces of information that are
free to vary in the calculation of an
estimate in the case we have here where
there's just one sample being taken the
degrees of freedom is just equal to the
sample size n minus one and this is
fairly easy to see so in our example
here we have 50 data points and our
sample mean is 3.2 that's the average of
all those 50 data points but here's the
thing
once we know 49 of those data points as
well as the mean we automatically know
the fiftieth data point so there are 49
independent pieces of information that
are free to vary here before we know the
50th so 50 minus one equals 49 degrees
of freedom here so coming back to our
example you can use R or you can use a
table like this one now confidence
intervals will generally make use of the
two-tailed probability up top so we're
gonna do 1 minus our confidence level
that's point nine five to get point zero
five up at the top and basically it's
just because the range of values not in
our confidence interval aren't just on
one side they're gonna be both less than
and greater than the range in our
interval then note that our degrees of
freedom are 49 now this particular table
actually jumps from 40 to 60 where the
degrees of freedom are listed on the
left hand side now generally it's good
practice to use the lower degree of
freedom because it just ends up giving
you a higher multiplier and increasing
the variability and the width of the
interval and it's just a way of being
more risk-averse
but anyway we use this table we line up
the 40 degrees of freedom with the point
zero five two-tailed probability and we
get a value of T equals two point zero
two one now if we use R we end up with
the more precise T equals two point zero
zero nine six now I like using R so for
the rest of this example that's what
we're going to use for T now all we have
to do is plug all these numbers into the
formula over here and we solve for a
confidence interval of two point eight
five nine two three point five for one
so based on this exercise that we've
just done we are ninety-five
confident that the true population mean
number of hours that Americans spend on
their phones per day is between two
point eight five nine and three point
five four one now there are some more
important definitions here to understand
one of them is that 95% number we've
been talking about so much that is your
confidence level the other is that
confidence interval that you just
created in the first place that 95%
number or your confidence level is
really just a property of the process
itself and that basically tells us that
if we repeated this process over and
over again that is we kept taking
repeated random samples computing
different confidence intervals we would
expect 95% of those resulting confidence
intervals to contain the true number
that we're trying to estimate here then
that interval means that were 95%
confident based on the process that we
used that that true number is within
that interval that we just generated so
I'm gonna restate it here we are 95%
confident that the true population mean
number of hours that Americans spend on
their phones per day is between two
point eight five nine and three point
five for one hours now that is not the
same thing as saying the probability is
95% that the true mean is between two
point eight five nine and three point
five four one remember at the beginning
of this video I mentioned the true mean
is a fixed number so it's either between
those two numbers in our interval or
it's not so that true probability is
either 0 or 1 just as a disclaimer to
all of this most of this makes the
assumption that we're operating as a
frequentist rather than as a bayesian
and that's generally the way most people
in the everyday world when they're
talking about confidence intervals
that's what they're doing even if they
don't necessarily realize that they're
doing it frequentist vs. bayesian is
totally a subject for a different video
and it's one of the most hotly debated
topics in the entire statistical
community but among people who use the
Bayesian framework you're going to hear
the term credible interval used
occasionally in that case we don't
assume that the population mean is fixed
in value and you can talk about there
being a probability that that number is
within the range that you generate with
your credible interval but again that's
a different subject for a different day
and that's an entirely different
framework from what most people think of
when they talk about confidence
intervals now it has been my personal
experience in working with clients that
almost all of them have at least some
understanding of what a confidence
interval represents not all of them do
but most will and frankly a lot of them
will appreciate if not totally expect
than if you're estimating some quantity
you're also providing some range of
uncertainty with it however invariably
where you're going to run into problems
is not over how narrow or how wide your
interval is or over the confidence level
that you select it's over actually
finding a random sample because just
think about it from my example it would
be extremely difficult to find 50 people
who would actually provide a
representative sample of all Americans
especially as it relates to something as
interesting as phone usage just think
phone usage varies over a tremendous
number of factors such as your age
probably whether you're in a rural or
urban area your gender probably
different things like that so actually
getting a random sample would take some
extremely rigorous sample design so this
is just an overview of confidence
intervals the process will be
essentially the same and the definitions
will not change no matter what your
parameter of interest here is as long as
we're treating the problem as a
frequentist and not as a Bayesian go
ahead and try to include these when
you're working on an applied data
science problem and your stakeholder
asks you to estimate or infer something
about some unknown quantity just
understand how the random sample aspect
could affect both your estimate and the
amount of uncertainty about your
estimate your stakeholders will thank
you for asking those kinds of questions
so thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it and you'd like to support my
work the most helpful thing that you
could do
for me would be to share this video
otherwise please consider smashing the
like button and then I'll see you all in
the not so distant future until then
Richard on data